Cristóbal Porque ve Ahora la Casa Blanca
la necesidad de bajarle el tono a las
declaraciones de biden sobre el riesgo
de un Armagedón nuclear
porque aunque la Casa Blanca se toma En
serio estas amenazas de Vladimir Putin
ha reiterado No solamente la Casa Blanca
sino también el departamento de estado
que no hay evidencias suficiente de que
Rusia precisamente vaya a usar armas
nucleares en Ucrania es cierto dice la
casa blanca que la presidente se refirió
a esta Apocalipsis que esta amenaza de
Apocalipsis que no ocurría desde 1962 en
la crisis de misiles de Cuba pero cariño
Jean Pierre la jefe de prensa de la Casa
Blanca reiteró que pues era importante
precisamente rescatar que lo que se
aprendió Precisamente en esta crisis de
misiles en 1962 es que hay que bajarle
el tono a La retórica un argumento muy
similar al que los líderes europeos pues
han invitado a Estados Unidos a acoger a
empezar a practicar para bajarle el tono
a la amenaza nuclear y a estas amenazas
constantemente pues da en medios de
comunicación estatales Vladimir Putin
para que Estados Unidos precisamente no
siga jugando ese juego y Cristóbal que
inteligencia está manejando el gobierno
estadounidense sobre las intenciones de
Putin estamos ante un riesgo real de una
escala de atómica
precisamente no eso es lo que dice el
departamento de estado dice que no
tienen pruebas de que Vladimir Putin
vaya a usar armas nucleares en Ucrania
dice el departamento de estado dicen acá
en Washington varios analistas también
Que obviamente Putin está un poco contra
las cuerdas de Cara a la reciente
pérdida de territorios de Cara a la
escalada de las fuerzas ucranianas
recuperando terreno en este en esta
guerra que se adelanta en territorio
ucraniano y que por eso y además por el
tema de que los países occidentales
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea pues
no han querido precisamente escalar el
tono de la guerra y que precisamente eso
le ha dado cierta manera un espacio
ahora demir Putin para entonces escalar
La retórica para querer recibir cierto
cierta respuesta de parte de Estados
Unidos que de alguna manera alimente
esta necesidad entonces de de de de
Putin de
un poco la guerra en territorio
ucraniano pero Precisamente es lo que
argumentan analistas que pues esta
Victoria o está derrota que está
teniendo en este momento Vladimir Putin
en Ucrania es lo que impulsa al líder
ruso a hacer este tipo a continuar con
este tipo de amenazas sin embargo Pues
es de Resaltar que yo bailén ha hecho no
solamente esta semana sino en semanas
anteriores pues aclaraciones y
declaraciones fuertes contra Vladimir
Putin llamándolo como criminal de guerra
y diciendo que no puede seguir en el
poder Así que hay que tomarse con un
grano de sal estas declaraciones de el
presidente